- Les spectateurs ont répondu
présents mais sans se presser.
Chacun à son rythme, comme
si après deux ans de pandémie,
il fallait réapprendre à fêter
ensemble.
- C'est la première fois
qu'on emmène les enfants à
la fête du Canada, donc,
c'était important pour nous.
- Pour ces grands-parents
qui habitent la Colombie,
c'est un moment de retrouvailles
longuement attendu.
C'est important d'être
ici quand même?
- Ah oui, très important
pour qu'on "party" avec tous
les Canadiens, c'est très bon
pour nous.
- C'est aussi le retour
des traditions.
Et le temps d'apporter
des nouveautés à la cérémonie.
Pour la première fois,
les célébrations se sont
ouvertes par un moment
de réflexion avec
les communautés autochtones.
- Je suis très heureux d'être en
famille avec vous pour céléb
la fête du Canada cette année,
en personne!
- Ce contact en personne,
le premier ministre Trudeau
est visiblement heureux
de le retrouver.
- C'est vraiment l'esprit
de pouvoir se revoir, de pouvoir
serrer des mains, de pouvoir
s'accoter les uns
les autres.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Sur scène, Lisa Leblanc
ne boude pas son plaisir
de renouer avec le public.
♪ ♪ ♪
Pour la chanteuse manitobaine
d'origine ukrainienne, Chantal
Kreviazuk, c'est un moment
précieux. Une occasion unique et
touchante d'exprimer le soutien
du Canada à l'Ukraine.
- On est ici et on ne va
pas changer notre position.
On est ici pour vous,
et on ne va pas partir.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Malgré une foule clairsemée,
l'énergie ne manque pas.
Tant dans le public que
sur la scène.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais c'est impossible pour
Justin Trudeau d'ignorer
les divisions laissées par
la gestion de la pandémie
et les manifestations que
cela engendre.
- Pour ceux qui se sentent
un petit peu frustrés par
rapport à ce que l'on a dû
faire en tant que
pendant les dernières années,
mais on va rester ouverts,
"compassionnés".
- Si pour ce 155 anniversaire
du Canada, on a mis l'accent
sur la diversité et l'inclusion,
le défi post-pandémie sera
de rétablir l'unité au pays.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Ottawa.
♪ ♪ ♪